that's my future wife how dare you
do you hear that that's the sound of
hearts breaking
all over the globe because reggae john
page
was just spotted out with his rumored
girlfriend soccer player emily brown
he sounds surprised this place i am
paige who plays the duke of hastings on
the netflix series bridgerton
has been pretty tight-lipped about his
personal life
but he appeared to be pretty cozy with
brown
in fact the two were snapped straight up
embracing before jumping into the back
seat of a car
and heading to a private airport in
london last tuesday
it's good fun and it's great to kind of
have a jaw-dropping moment
paige looks happy and in love and we
love to see it
but of course fans of the hit show have
been hardcore
shipping paige's character and daphne
bridgerton played by phoebe denavere
and many have even hoped that all that
on-screen passion
would translate off screen but for now
seems paige and denavir are
simply just co-stars i cannot
marry her thankfully fans will get to
see more of the duke since the series
was renewed for a second season
last month but this time the focus will
be on jonathan bailey's anthony
bridgerton
with simone ashley starring as his love
interest
kate sharma and if you just can't wait
to get more of paige and season two
you're in luck the hunky star is hosting
saturday night live on february 20th
alongside musical guest bad bunny i
think that could be very exciting
as for that online chatter that the
actor could be cast as the next james
bond
well he weighed in during a recent stop
by the tonight show starring jimmy
fallon
if you're a brit and you do something of
any kind of renown that people regard
well
then people start saying the b word you
know it's like a merit badge you get the
b word merit badge
um but that's i don't think it's much
more than that i'm very very glad to
have the badge i'm glad to be in such a
wonderful company of people who have the
badge
yes it's a badge
you